استخدم الطرفان الروسي والاوكراني
المسيرات في بدايه الحرب لتحديد مواقع
العدو وتوجيه نيران المدفعيه لاستهدافها
غير ان دورها قد تزايد بصوره واضحه بعد
ذلك فقد كان المسيرات الاوكرانيه دور بارز
في استهداف مواقع قوات الروسيه في العديد
من مناطق القتال خاصه في هذا الاقليم
اقليم القرم الذي تسيطر عليه روسيا منذ
سنوات كانت اوكرانيا قد اعلنت في وقت سابق
شراءها 1400 طائره مسيره مؤخرا لكن معظمها
بهدف الاستطلاع كما انها تخطط لتطوير
نماذج قتاليه منها مسيرات انتحاريه لكنها
ذات مدى قريب وبالفعل وصلت المسيرات
الاوكرانيه الى عمق الداخل الروسي
واستهدفت مواقع عده كان اخرها موسكو بل
وصلت الى استهداف مبنى الكريم للنفسه كما
تقول موسكو في المقابل تستعين روسيا
بمسيارات تاتيها من دول اخرى ابرزها ايران
رغم امتلاكها ترسانه ضخمه من الاسلحه تلك
المسيرات استخدمتها في استهداف مدن في
العمق الاوكراني ككيف
ودسه وكذلك خرسون
تقارير عسكريه تحدثت عن ان تقنيات الحرب
الالكترونيه الروسيه قد قللت من فاعليه
طائرات الدرون الاوكرانيه خاصه تلك
المصنعه من قبل شركه دي جي اي الصينيه لكن
الاسباب التي دفعت الطرفين لهذا الاستخدام
المتزايد لمسيرات هي قله التكلفه الماديه
فهي ارخص بكثير من الترسانه التقليديه كما
انها ايضا تقلل كثيرا من الخسائر البشريه
في صفوف الجيش فضلا عن قدرتها على اصابه
الاهداف بدقه كل هذا يؤكد على ما يقوله
الكثير من العسكريين من ان هذه الطائرات
المسيره ستكون عنوانا للمرحله المقبله من
الحرب في اوكرانيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات